bonjour je m'appelle justin de france
aussi connu sous le nom de la prof sur
internet c'est principalement sur
youtube
et si aujourd'hui je remets ma casquette
de réalisatrice c'est pour vous parler
d'un projet en 2018 en plus de mes
vidéos historique habituel j'avais
décidé de me lancer dans la fiction
j'ai donc réalisé grâce à une fine
équipe et grâce à vos contributions
avoue spectateurs la première saison de
la websérie taille noir une série qui
met les science-fiction références
historiques et humour dans la saison une
donc on retrouvait les personnages de la
prof c'est à dire moi dans la vidéo
d'histoire
aliénor lucrecia % des personnages
récurrents de mes chroniques et on
comprenait pas pourquoi tous ces
personnages venant de différentes
époques se retrouver au 21ème siècle
quels étaient les enjeux ce qui se
passait alors ce qui va suivre
spoiled un petit peu la saison une donc
si vous ne l'avez pas encore vue et que
ça vous intéresse je vous invite à
passer à ce thème code qui vous
permettra de ne pas être spoilé mais
attention cet artiste en fait il y avait
des cyber historiens qui vivent au 23ème
siècle et qui font voyager leurs
ancêtres à leur époque afin de leur
demander de raconter leurs souvenirs
parce que le problème c'est qu'au 23e
siècle il ya plus d'archivés plus rien
et donc les historiens sont un peu bas
sans avoir grand chose à se mettre sous
la dent et le problème avec les cyber
historiens c'était que l'un d'entre eux
l'une d'entre eux plus tôt c'était la
descendante de la prof stagiaire mois et
du fou est bien avec tout ça mis
ensemble il y avait des bonnes
temporaire et certains de ses ancêtres
se retrouver au 21ème siècle
au lieu d'atterrir un troisième siècle
c'était le cas d'ailleurs des glacières
de castries le side-car a quand même
beaucoup
heureusement que les gardiens et c'est
un bon pas trop endettés dans le cas des
passants et pourquoi je vous parle de
tout ça parce que j'ai écrit la saison 2
en réalité cette saison 2 j'ai déjà
écrites depuis un moment mais mon
réaliser une série c'est fatigant cette
demande de l'investissement et donc il
me fallait un peu de temps pour me
remettre du tournage de la saison une
haie puis actionnez sur deux projets ce
que je sais écrire
quand même entre temps il va se passer
plein de choses dans cette saison 2
c'est une saison en deux épisodes
un peu plus long que ceux de la saison
une et avec forcément de nouveaux enjeux
de nouveaux personnages qui apparaissent
de nouveaux méchants aussi
personnellement je me suis beaucoup
amusé à écrire
il paraît qu'elle est drôle et j'ai
envie de la réaliser voilà et bien sûr
je ne réalise pas la saison de toute
seule je suis accompagné de comédiens et
d'une équipe technique dont je vais vous
présenter un membre qui va apparaître
maintenant
bonjour bonjour bas mais tu peux te
présenter donc bonjour moi c'est
françois je suis assistant réalisateur
moi mon travail sur la série consiste à
décharger la réalisatrice
histoire de faire avancer les choses de
façon plus agréable et plus efficace
bien qu'elle soit très efficace pour
l'instant ce qui a déjà été fait c'est
par exemple des documents de pré
production comme les documents
dépouillement ou pour simplifier en gros
ça consiste à faire des listes d accès
soit et des lieux de tournage pour que
qu'au moment du tournage tout soit prêt
en ardres qu'on est tous les accessoires
qui nous faut qu'on est tous les gens
qui nous faut mieux qu'il nous faut tous
déjà quasi tous nos mieux d'ailleurs
et c'est bien d'avoir des lieux où
tourner pas mal parce que ça parce que
sinon la honte on dort dehors c'est un
yacht et donc l'euro le but de
l'assistant réalisateur c'est de
décharger le réalisateur d'une partie de
sa charge d'autant qu'en l'occurrence le
réalisateur est aussi scénariste acteur
donc ça fait beaucoup et aussi au moment
du tournage d'ailleurs c'est ça au
moment du tournage comme tu joues de
rôle dans la série tout apparaîtra tu
apparaître régulièrement devant la
caméra est donc ce serait intéressant
d'avoir quelqu'un qui n'est pas
forcément la réalisatrice mais mais qui
peut quand même servir de jointure et
tenir les choses en place voilà parce
que quand je suis devant la caméra je ne
peux pas être derrière ces justes
scientifique pour la saison une donc on
avait financé la série par grounding
c'est-à-dire par financement
participatif si vous étiez déjà là vous
l'aviez vu passer il s'agissait d'un
financement puis par la plateforme ulule
pour la saison une on avait rassemblé
3300 euros qui nous avait permis de
tourner avec du matériel
en achetant un petit peu d'accessoires
en défrayant surtout des déplacements et
en nourrissant les gens ce qui est très
important et en les rémunérant un tout
petit peu que pas vraiment parler de la
minoration mais disons un petit bonus
par jour quoi donc ça c'était pour la
saison une scie pour la saison 2 on
voulait retrouver ces mêmes conditions
de tournage somme toute assez modeste
mais voilà qui était suffisante
il nous faudrait six mille euros d'après
nos calculs en comptant aussi des
contreparties bien sûr ce qui part dans
l'est dans les pourcentages hululer des
impôts donc voilà six mille euros c'est
ce qui nous permettrait de tourner avec
les mêmes conditions que la saison une
qui était un modeste mais tout à fait
suffisantes pour ce qu'on avait besoin
de faire
on n'est pas sur un tournage
professionnels mais bien sûr ce genre de
campagne hull c'est un peu tout ou rien
donc on a prévu plusieurs paliers tout
de même que tu vas nous presser
oui donc il ya le tout premier palier le
palier à 5000 euros
c'est à partir de ce palier là que la
série devient réalisable et sans
rémunération pour les comédiens une
équipe technique ensuite bye alias
minéraux ou là
cette rémunération pour les comédiens et
l'équipe technique oui paris comme ils
travaillent dur ils sont contents de
loin un petit quelque chose quand même
sa chance et très peu voilà au moins
pouvoir faire un petit quelque chose à
tous les gens qui s'investissent
allemand voilà et ensuite il y à le
payer 7500 euros qui est lui permet
d'investir un peu plus dans tout ce qui
est costumé chose qui pourrait
apparaître à l'écran - costumes
accessoires puisqu'il ya des nouveaux
personnages donc forcément des nouveaux
costumes pour les cas cette fois je ne
peux pas puisé dans mes réserves de
vieux costumes donc oui il va falloir
investir un peu et jour là dessous plus
ça peut être quelque chose de joli est
pas quelque chose de deux magasins
déguisements quoi après le palier 7500
euros et le palier à 9000 euros qui lui
permet d'améliorer encore de mettre
encore un coup de rein sur les costumes
et le matériel technique si on a besoin
d'eau si évidemment il ya un budget
matériels techniques sont a besoin de
louer d'acheter des choses et ça ça peut
permettre de l'augmenter aussi est aussi
d'organiser une projection avec le
panier à nashville comme on l'avait fait
pour la saison une voix ça serait bien
de pouvoir faire quelque chose de bien
en fin de série pour marquer le coup et
vous invitez évidemment et pour ça il ya
le palier à 9000 et on a un dernier
palier le palier à 11000 euros qui lui
permettrait d'augmenter les
rémunérations des comédiens et des
équipes de doubles tout le monde
donc voilà tout ça ce sont des pailles
et évidemment qu'on a prévu au cas où si
on atteint 5000 euros on est déjà
contents si on à part si milan est déjà
super content et voilà l'idée serait de
tourner cette série cet été comme je
disais sur une semaine cette fois en
diffuserait pas en week-end pourrait
vraiment essayé de rassembler toute
l'équipe dont le nord de la france et
de tout temps d'un jour parce que ça met
une ambiance un peu plus sympa
évidemment donc on a besoin de vous pour
ça comme je les dis cette vidéo cerd
annonce et bien sûr à la fin de la vidéo
ou alors dans la description vous
retrouverai le lien ulule qui vous
permet de consulter en corps une fois
tous les détails qui sont mis par écrit
le détail des contreparties aussi parce
qu'on a prévu lé té choix de choses pour
vous et le détail du tournage des
comédiens qui sont présents et c'est
pour apprendre plein de choses par des
jolis visuels
donc n'hésitez pas à aller sur la page
de l'ul la partager le plus possible
s'il vous plaît et bien sûr contribuer
si vous le voulez et si vous pouvez tous
les montants sont bienvenus parce que ça
peut vraiment vraiment ce genre de
campagne ça ça marche avec des montants
très faible mais c'est là le nombre de
montants très faible qui fait qu'on
atteint autant moins faible ouais en
gros ce que non voilà je mets très
régulièrement des petites news sur
facebook et twitter ce sera l'occasion
de reposter la saison une les petites
vidéos tournage et photos de tournage
que vous n'avez jamais vu mais mais qui
permettront de rappeler côté marques
existent il y aurait également des live
qui seront organisés pour vous présenter
un peu plus l'équipe technique et
l'équipe des comédiens parce qu'il n'ya
pas que nous deux il ya des gens aussi
plus de gens bien d'autres gens d'autres
gens bien et donc le premier live aura
lieu le dimanche 21 mars c'est à dire
tout bientôt
on organisera probablement deux autres
live à mi parcours où va essayer
d'organiser des quiz des petits trucs
sympas historiques ou alors sur la
science fiction parce que c'est un peu
des mes passions conjointe et les deux
choses qui sont là pas rentrer dans ta
et marque
et puis enfin un dernier live voix en
fin de parcours pour faire le bilan de
la campagne me relancer une dernière
fois s'il le faut et c'est quoi va
essayer de par le but pas de harceler
mais de créer du contenu sympathique
pour
pour dynamiser la campagne voilà je vous
renvoie donc vers la page ulule où vous
aurez plein d'informations et vous
pourrez effectuer les dons en question
si vous le souhaitez et si vous avez des
questions en toujours n'hésitez pas à
les poster en commentaire juste en
dessous de cette vidéo
j'ai toujours voulu faire ça et oui et
nous aussi répondre je suis prête à fait
nous alerterons et vous pouvez aussi
d'ailleurs survenu le poser des
questions en cadre de la faq et
peut-être que je me mettrai aussi les
questions posées ici dans la faq lui
mais alors tout cas c'est plusieurs
moyens de me contacter et de nous
contacter l'équipe vous pouvez aussi
bien sûr suivre les choses sur twitter
la prof est aussi sur facebook sur la
page facebook que la prof également
merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout j'espère que le projet
vous intéresse que vous avez envie que
la saison dota noir voile toujours
autant que nous et à bientôt du goût à
bientôt immersif en moins
[Musique]